some might argue that 2011's the thing
didn't copy the 1982 original as well as
the titular monster does its victims but
fans seem to disagree judging by its
popularity on Netflix
though some movies may not fare well
during their tenure as a theatrical
release there is always a chance for a
movie to gain new viewership when it
comes to streaming services coughing up
the amount of money required to see a
film typically makes some audiences
apprehensive and it seems like the only
movies that make money these days are
Avengers level outings luckily Netflix
is there to help gain some new
viewership for movies that may not have
been seen by a whole lot of people in
theaters this is the case for 2011's the
thing open up the movie catalog on
Netflix and the thing is not just the
first film many viewers will see
advertised but it is also the third most
popular movie on Netflix at this moment
as a prequel remake of 1982's the thing
the 2011 movie features the familiar and
terrifying story of an isolated Research
Center located in Antarctica starring
Joel Edgerton Mary Elizabeth Winstead
adewale akanoye agbaje and Ulrich
Thompson the things seem like it would
be an absolute slam dunk as a new
iteration of the Beloved science fiction
classic
unfortunately the 2011 version failed to
compel theatrical audiences and some
consider it one of the worst sci-fi
remakes of all time
the thing tells a story of a far-flung
research settlement and its assortment
of scientists who soon find themselves
under attack by a shape-changing alien
this plot is similar to the original
version from 1982 and the paranoia that
these individuals feel often Drive the
plot forward as they wonder who they can
trust when there is an extraterrestrial
organism that can kill assimilate and
mimic other forms of life
audiences at the time didn't feel the
need to check out the movie and the film
missed the Mark at the box office the
thing was made for 38 million dollars
but the movie failed to break even
generating just shy of 17 million
dollars in the United States and 10.5
million dollars in international markets
besides just failing to make money the
thing received a middling reception with
Rotten Tomatoes showing that the movie
has a 34 critic score and a 42 audience
score despite a lackluster reception
some critics saw potential in the 2011
movie Keith in the movies wrote fans of
the 1982 classic will want to see it and
should find a lot to like while it trips
itself up with an overloaded cast in a
few scenes which feel like they belong
in another film it does deliver that
almost old school sci-fi monster movie
feel
although 2011's the thing failed to
Garner a lot of attention during its
original run it's dominating Netflix at
the moment perhaps audiences were simply
waiting for an opportune time to watch
the movie as the original the thing is
considered a classic now the 2011's
version is just a click away it seems
like viewers are giving the movie
Another Chance even though there are
major changes from the original Source
material director Matthias van heenigan
Jr spoke with den of geek in 2012 about
some of the changes and ideas he had
while approaching 2011's the thing which
included how he helped rewrite the first
version of the script and had Kate Lloyd
as the main character as opposed to The
Originals RJ McCready
heenigan added that the cast didn't need
much inspiration when taking on their
respective roles he said everyone who
was part of this saw and loved John
Carpenter's movie I didn't have to
explain anything about that sense of
awkwardness because there was a great
example of it in the movie we saw the
movie all together before we started so
it all felt very natural it was already
familiar to everybody
the similarities to the original film as
well as the differences seemed to
finally have been embraced thanks to
Netflix
[Music]